là
le prétend après bientôt mandela est
libre son nom historique s'est produit
cet après midi à l'afrique du sud le
symbole le mythe mandela est redevenu à
la fois un homme et à leaders politiques
dont le dressage est sera déterminant
pour l'avenir de son peuple et de la fin
des trains bonsoir libéré à 15h15 cet
après-midi nelson mandela est arrivé il
ya tout juste une demi heure à l'hôtel
de ville du cap
le chef historique de la nc a pris la
parole devant des centaines de milliers
de personnes
nous venons de recevoir les premières
images commentaires à chaud hélène
risacher avec près de trois heures de
retard nelson mandela apparaît enfin au
bal cour de l'hôtel de ville du cap
l'impatience est à son comble pour les
milliers de sympathisants de lindsey qui
s'entassent sur la place des troubles
viennent d'éclater alentours faisant un
mort et plusieurs blessés
camarades amis sud africains
je vous salue tous au nom de la paix de
la démocratie et de la liberté pour tous
je me tiens ici devant vous non pas en
tant que prophète mais entend câble
serviteur de vous le peuple
votre peine et votre cri fils héroïques
ont rendu possible ma venue ici et
nelson mandela salue la haine ces
leaders de la grande marche vers la
liberté dit-il
il remercie tous ceux qui se sont battus
pour sa libération et contre l'apartheid
les hommes les organisations la jeunesse
aussi ces jeunes lui ont dit il qui sont
l'avant-garde et la force de notre lutte
contre l'oppression
après ce meeting géant nelson mandela
doit donner une conférence de presse
on attendait première déclaration
politique de nelson mandela
une ligne directrice pour la stratégie
de la mc face à la nouvelle donne en
afrique du sud
traduction quasi simultanés d'hélène
risacher les images qui arrivent au fur
et à mesure en provenance du cap nous y
reviendrons à la fin de cette édition
nous reviendrons donc sur le discours
que tient en ce moment même
nelson mandela à l'hôtel de ville notre
invité hendrick games and with vous êtes
l'ambassadeur d'afrique du sud à paris
quel rôle politique attendez vous de la
part de nelson mandela northman des
leurs est une personne très importante
et les présidents hadi et que monsieur
mandela and roll très importante à jouer
dans la manière mais que vous savez il
est membre des line 6 et je crois avec
la m6 commencera maintenant l'ailé
négociations pour négociations avec le
gouvernement vous attendez que nelson
mandela soit le négociateur entre
l'insee et le gouvernement c'est pour le
raincy pour décider je ne sais pas si
monsieur mandela sur les énigmes à eau
le seul interlocuteur avec le
gouvernement meelia naturellement des
autres partis est aussi qui le désirent
participer à la négociation par exemple
plusieurs a bouclé ses chefs d une
quatre sous loue ses lotos les autres
groupes non puisque vous parlez de
négociation se pose le problème de
l'avenir politique de l'afrique du sud
de l'afrique du sud la nc a toujours
parlé d'un homme une voix des élections
libres en afrique du sud
est-ce possible et cela conduirait
inévitablement à la victoire de la
grande majorité noire à votre pays oui
dès l'annoncé a demandé un homme un vote
dans une état unitaire pour le
gouvernement il ya pas un problème avec
un homme un vote mais dans ce système
pour négocier que tous les mineurs
étaient d'un autre pays pour la
protection par exemple l'une était en
fédérale conférence je ne sais pas mais
c'est pour négocier ces négociations
alors messieurs les louise vous rester
avec moi la liaison en direct maintenant
avec hubert coudurier notre envoyé
spécial il est à johannesburg hubert
vous suivez simultanément à la
télévision
d'afrique du sud le discours que tient
nelson mandela quelles sont les
réactions sur place tout d'abord dans le
bulletin à ce soir est
exceptionnellement prolongée rendra son
fait partie elle compte de
l'effervescence qui règne dans tout le
pays est intéressant c'est que le la
télévision vient de consacrer une longue
et prospectives de la vie de mandela
alors qu' il n'y a pas si longtemps la
presse n'avait pas le droit de cité
là il sait cette rétrospective rappelle
qu'à l'époque de son arrestation en 63
mandela eastwood c'est oliver tambo et
walter sisulu s'étaient réunis dans une
ferme aux environs durée des secours qui
fut lancée par la police au moment où la
haine et à les mettre sur pied une série
d'actions de sabotage qui témoignait du
passage de la résistance passive à
l'action violente mandela considère
aujourd'hui que ce changement de
stratégie était nécessaire pour laisser
contre le gouvernement de l'apartheid
même si le président de plaire en
détaillant le cloud et abandonne en ce
qui concerne la télévision sud-africaine
est ce qu est le discours de nelson
mandela en ce moment à l'hôtel de ville
est toujours retransmis non nous n'avons
pas nous n'avons pas demandé la la
télévision sud-africaine série de
réactions qui sont toutes très favorable
de ça va de la direction de la sg à
lusaka au président zambien kenneth
kaunda ou chef zoulou t
shikata il ya aussi une réaction un peu
négative qui est celle de l'udf la
branche politique de la haine ces
deux-là syndicats la cosatu qui viennent
de faire une déclaration sur les morts
et endeuillé la la libération de mandela
est contrainte selon ces organisations
avec que la liesse populaire
l'organisation qui demande à la pause et
à la police d'agir de façon plus
responsable
merci retour maintenant aux images de
l'après-midi nelson mandela en liberté
tenant la main de son épouse
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure en titre
des centaines de milliers d'hommes et de
femmes ont pleuré danser chanter
aujourd'hui en afrique du sud
récit d'une journée extraordinaire
philippe pisteurs l'attend sous un
soleil de plomb
des centaines de partisans de l' insee
devant la prison de parle depuis les
premières heures du matin la presse
les télévisions du monde entier venus
saisir l'instant historique une heure de
retard pour mettre fin à plus d'un quart
de siècle de captivité il est 15 heures
15 à paris nelson mandela et sa famille
ni ses premiers pas d'homme libre
les premiers pas hésitants après 27 ans
6 mois et 6 jours d'emprisonnement
l'émotion des membres de la famille du
vieux leader devant leurs récepteurs et
un bref bain de foule du symbole vivant
de la lutte anti-apartheid aucune
déclaration
le couple mandela prend aussitôt la
route précédé d'un immense cortège
direction l'hôtel de ville du cap
cinquante mille personnes sont déjà
massés là attendant les premières
paroles publiques de leurs leaders
atmosphère de kermesse la ville pavoisée
aux couleurs de la haine c'est une
journée historique malheureusement
entachée par la violence près de l'hôtel
de ville alors que la foule s'impatiente
et en attend de son leader la police a
dû tirer sur des jeunes noirs occupés a
pillé des boutiques
il y aurait au moins un mort 26 blessés
monsieur l'ambassadeur de réaction qui
contraste un petit peu d'ailleurs dans
ce commentaire de philippe pisteurs vous
avez vu sourire tout d'abord à l'émotion
de cette population noire
qui fêtait la libération de nelson
mandela où il a terminé ses essais c'est
clair après beaucoup d'années
monsieur mandela est une personnalité
bien connue d'un film à l'afrique du sud
mais tout le monde et 80 tout le monde
en afrique du sud
beaucoup des nôtres habitants comme vous
savez vue sont très exigeantes excitante
et tim clio rue pourquoi ne pas l'avoir
libéré plus tôt l'asa en voyant je vous
vois sourire et pourtant je dirais qu'il
ya six mois encore vous auriez justifier
la présence en prison nelson mandela
nous avons beaucoup de violence et
d'afrique du sud
1280 de 4 5 6 et 7
et maintenant après les discussions
entre notre président à monsieur mandela
est aussi avec centre monsieur mandela
et les membres de l'ansea ont décidé que
maintenant c'est le temps pour libérer
monsieur mandela
c'est la prochaine étape dans leur route
de réformes la fin de la partie
oui absolument légale le gouvernement
est déterminé pour des mains de la
partie complètement nous verrons sur la
violence va l'instant mais nous allons
voir tout de suite les réactions cet
après midi dans les goguettes au noir
oui notamment à soweto où l'excitation
était à son paroxysme reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux
hubert coudurier philippe guinet
et
le stade chabou lundi à soweto en milieu
d'après midi plus de 20000 personnes
viennent d'apprendre la sortie de prison
de mandela yvelines ses camarades
lancent les organisateurs de la
manifestation qui réunit les principales
organisations politiques syndicales
étudiantes
réveille toi mon pays j'ai peur je suis
émerveillé car nous travaillons tous
pour la paix lance ce poète célèbre ici
la libération de mandela est d'abord
vécu comme un défi au pouvoir blanc par
les jeunes qui n'ont cessé de se
radicaliser
refusant la résignation de leurs parents
aussi
ce notable qui appelle à la
réconciliation des noirs et des blancs
et ils promptement sifflet mabiala is
mandela est un catalyseur de la liberté
je pense que c'est plus qu'un faiseur de
paix il peut rassembler tout le monde
sait pourquoi je crois en lui
pendant ce temps la foule s'agglomèrent
tour de la petite maison de mandela
dédaignant la somptueuse villa que lui a
fait construire sa femme oui à la
lecture des journaux car bien peu
d'habitants des townships pour la
télévision
c'est d'abord la surprise personne ne
connaissait mandela dont seules des
photos biais d'un quart de siècle avait
été diffusée la communauté noire attend
donc son leader
véritable mythe vivant qui porte sur lui
le poids tragique du passé et l'espoir
fragile que fait naître l'avenir
plusieurs manifestations ont salué
aujourd'hui apparue la libération de
nelson mandela musique et champagne
devant l'ambassade d'afrique du sud donc
à paris et puis cortège et danse à la
bastille à l'appel de sos racisme les
images ici vous parlez de champagne
devant l'ambassade d'afrique du sud
et puis elle souhaite racisme donc qui
appelait à un rassemblement à la
bastille tout de suite maintenant les
réactions dans la classe politique
française elles sont nombreuses elles
ont été sélectionnées par christian
bèzes laurent fabius président de
l'assemblée nationale dans un télégramme
adressé aujourd'hui à nelson mendela
invite le leader sud africain à venir en
france dès que possible nous vous
accueillerons un déconneur et une
immense joie écrit monsieur fabius
pierre bérégovoy indique que l'attitude
de la france sur les sanctions
économiques vis-à-vis de l'afrique du
sud dépendra de l'évolution de la
situation là bas il faut explique le
ministre de l'économique de nouveaux
actes suivent la libération de mandela
c'est une joie immense déclare et hier
soir georges marchais ajoutant aussitôt
son regret de n'avoir pas vu les
autorités françaises boycotter le régime
raciste d'afrique du sud politique en
france maintenant selon que la bouteille
sera à moitié pleine ou sera à moitié
vide on parlera ce soir du succès ou de
l'échec relatif de jacques chirac
aujourd'hui aux assises du rpr la motion
juppé qu'il descendait a certes obtenu
deux tiers des mandats mais c'est bien
charles pasqua qui apparaît ce soir
comme le principal bénéficiaire de ces
assises michel rivière le débat clair ou
pas clair a eu lieu et vous l'avez
tranché
trancher est-ce vraiment le terme même
s'il reste président du rpr sa motion
ayant obtenu plus de 68% des voix
jacques chirac va devoir compter avec
une opposition interne
il n'a pas obtenu le plébiscite il est
ce qu'on appelle en effet la motion de
charles pasqua et philippe seguin avec
31 38 position de roi a trouvé chez les
militants un écho bien plus large que
les sondages nous laissaient prévoir
d'ailleurs quand philippe seguin et
charles pasqua se congratule c'est parce
qu'ils savent déjà que le mouvement va
devoir compter avec eux et ce matin
philippe seguin avait enfoncé le clou
est loin d'adopter une position de
retrait il réaffirmait les forces la
nécessité du renouveau au sein du rpr
ce débat n'est donc pas un débat
médiocre un d-pad dérisoire
un débat éphémère c'était un débat
nécessaire
c'est un débat légitime voire une
certitude ce débat reste effectivement
ouvert avant même de connaître le
résultat des votes
charles pasqua ne s'y trompe pas
s'offrait le luxe de parodier une phrase
de jacques chirac en salle de presse aux
passants
comme l'a dit monsieur chirac mur a ni
vainqueur ni vaincu serons tous unis ce
soir
il y aura un gagnant il ya bientôt n'y
aura pas de gagnants iront à paris
berlin revient non plus en plus tôt
alain juppé y ont été confirmés
secrétaire général du rpr par jacques
chirac
d'autres épreuves de force sont à
prévoir fort de ses 31 %
charles pasqua tentera certainement à
nouveau d'infléchir la ligne politique
du rpr avant les échéances électorales
alors éric pierrot ni gagnant ni vaincus
ni vainqueur ni perdant se mélangent un
petit peu on al'impression finalement
que leur père est toujours ce soir dans
une situation pour le moins confuse
oui ce soir le fr et dans la situation
la plus inconfortable qu'il pouvait
imaginer avant les assises
pourquoi par tout simplement parce que
le débat n'est pas tranché
les assises n'ont pas mis un terme à ce
débat qui va donc se poursuivre pendant
des mois qui va empêcher le rpr de se
mettre en ordre de bataille et de jouer
tout simplement son rôle de parti
d'opposition alors alain juppé a été
renommé cet après-midi secrétaire
général du rpr par jacques chirac il a
été renommé mais on peut se demander ce
soir pour combien de temps pourra-t-il
résister longtemps la pression des plus
de 30% des militants qui contestent
ouvertement son aspect technocratique et
aussi ses choix politiques
jacques chirac lui même ne pourra plus
non plus ignorer la volonté charles
pasqua jacques chirac voulait sortir
renforcée de ces assises
force est de constater que ce sport il
entend affaibli au sein de son propre
parti
et évidemment au sein de l'opposition un
animaux michel m'en a pas parlé
aujourd'hui
non mais il a été copieusement sifflé en
revanche michel noir dès demain va
relancer son projet de fusion du rpr et
de l'udf
un projet qui provoque déjà la colère
des militants gaulliste y voit une perte
d'identité et qui ne fait en plus que
compliqué beaucoup les choses
pour jacques chirac merci eric pierrot
les autres faits marquants de
l'actualité en france à l'étranger sous
forme de télégrammes commentaires tout
de suite françois 3
quinze mille interne chef de clinique et
membres des professions libérales de
santé ont manifesté dimanche à paris
partie de la pyramide du louvre ils sont
arrivés à 18 heures devant le ministère
de la santé une délégation devait être
reçue
les médecins en grève depuis quatre
semaines souhaite une médecine libérale
après cinq jours de blocus retour à la
normale au tunnel du mont blanc les
engagements pris par le gouvernement et
a nié envers les transporteurs qui
bloquaient l'accès au tunnel ont permis
de rétablir complètement la circulation
dans les deux sens plus de perturbations
pour l'arrivée des vacanciers à bucarest
plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
manifesté aujourd'hui devant la
télévision ou men il accuse les médias
d'être au service du fond de salut
national ils réclament la fin de la
censure et une télévision libre par
ailleurs la roumanie serait paralysée
par des milliers de routiers ils
réclament de meilleures conditions de
travail
nous aurons maintenant la page sportive
avec un grand coup de chapeau à la
skieuse carole merle deuxième super
géants consécutifs à méribel deuxième
victoire consécutive pour la française
comme en terre ennemie gaudi cheli
carole merle au sommet de son art sur la
piste olympique du super géant de
méribel deux victoires en deux jours sur
de neige radicalement différente
c'est la marque des grandes championnes
ce matin sur un tracé à nouveau très
technique où la neige fraîche
interdisait toute cassure de rythme
carole merle a trouvé la trajectoire
idéale autour des portes mais aussi
entre les portes
là où la légèreté et la vitesse font la
différence
désormais en tête de la coupe du monde
de super g en carole merle devient la
référence pour les descentes lé slalom
géant à venir derrière elle ce matin la
jeune allemande sizing heures à 62
centièmes c'est la plus belle course de
sa carrière et à 79 centièmes la grande
maria walliser qui s'en ira à la fin de
cette saison et qui a donc salué pour la
dernière fois aujourd'hui un public
français en coupe du monde de ski
football 25e journée du championnat de
france de première division cet
après-midi les ténors ont gagné en
l'occurrence marseille face au racing
les résultats tout de suite sur ce
panneau et bordeaux dépend de quand nous
allons y revenir en images match nul
entre auxerre et sochaux pas de
changement au placement en revanche nice
qui était dernier et lé gagner à
toulouse de ce fait les niçois
rejoignent à la 19e place montpellier
toutes les équipes pratiquement depuis
la 11ème place se tiennent dans le même
classement après les résultats je vous
le disais les temps forts de la
rencontre cet après midi entre bordeaux
et caen les girondins ont failli et
raccrocher commentaire d'alain dorgans
dans le combat que se livrent à distance
marseille et bordeaux statu quo à
domicile les girondins ont brisé
l'anathème selon lequel les normands ont
remporté tous leurs matchs devant
bordeaux depuis leur accession en
première division
cette fois c'est bien le onze de raymond
goethals qui s'est imposé mais ce n'est
pas faute d'avoir à siéger les beats de
caen dès la 4e minute un centre de
lizarazu et jean philippe duron voit sa
frappe tendue pour les in extremis par
montanier
le même lizarazu révélation des
girondins de bordeaux sera à l'origine
du premier but de son équipe l'arrière
basque centre et dépose le ballon sur la
tête de l'inévitable den boer ouvre la
marque en deuxième mi-temps le principe
des vases communicants sera dopté quand
bordeaux se relâche c'est quand qu'ils
accélèrent et fabrice divert altruiste
qu'il et égalise pour qu'on un but qui
entretient le suspense
retour à la case départ pour les
bordelais qui prendront définitivement
l'avantagé à la suite de ce corner tiré
par klaus allofs à la réception duquel
den boer double la mise et permet à son
équipe de se tailler un succès à
l'arraché un but capital pour les
girondins de bordeaux dans la mesure
leur grand rival marseille n'a pas fait
dans la dentelle passe au racing club de
paris un rugby une sélection française
totalement remaniée pour aller à
edimbourg samedi prochain en écosse dans
le cadre du tournoi des cinq nations
regardez bien l'équipe qui va s'afficher
devant vous honte à ceux de biarritz
remplace andrieu mesnel passe au centre
car cambérabéro revient à l'ouverture
henri sens remplace le capitaine de
l'équipe de france pierre berbizier
l'air mais arrivent en troisième ligne
aile carminati de béziers remplace
roumat qui monte en deuxième ligne à la
place d'air banni enfin pujol remplace
garvey une équipe de france remaniée on
espère qu'elle sera mieux se comporter
que face à l'angleterre samedi dernier
au parc la plupart des internationaux
étaient sur le terrain cet après midi
pour participer aux quarts de finale du
challenge yves du manoir avec au
programme un certain agen toulouse
commentaires didier balèze l'élite du
rugby français s'affrontent cet
après-midi dans le challenge yves du
manoir une trentaine de postulants
quinze de france sont sous les yeux des
sélectionneurs ici montferrand en jaune
avec lhermet face à lui les dacquois
rodriguez et room à dax qu'il effectue
un cavalier seul invaincu en championnat
inscrit un essai par luc pillot à la fin
du temps réglementaire 16 à 16
prolongation
montferrand plus frais physiquement
s'impose par un essai de riou score
final 23 19 pour l'asm à lure de
narbonne bayonne en bleu les basques
toujours capable de pratiquer leur
meilleur rugby inscrivent un essai par
lagisquet de l'ailier du quinze de
france
mais narbonne favori logique réplique
par fabre entre les poteaux et se
qualifie de justesse pour les demi
finales
15 12 autres résultats à l'élimination
surprise de toulon face à grenoble 24 à
9 mai la rencontre choc c'est ici
toulouse champion de france face à agen
en bleu l'équipe de berbizier privé de
plusieurs titulaires des marques et aux
planchers aiguelèze à la 9e minute
inscrit le premier essai plus qui n'est
pas au mieux de sa forme à l'image de
l'ouvreur charvet ne répliquent que
mollement score final 18 12
pour agen
retour maintenant au premier titre de
cette édition la libération de nelson
mandela le chef historique de la nc est
arrivé en fin d'après midi à l'hôtel de
ville du cap tout de suite la suite de
son discours avec un commentaire
simultanée de jean marc pitte
je réitère ma demande pour que cesse
immédiatement l'état d'urgence
je réclame la liberté de tous les
prisonniers politiques et pas seulement
de quelques-uns il faut que notre peuple
saisi cette occasion afin que le
processus de démocratisation soit rapide
et ininterrompue discours de nelson
mandela pratiquement en direct de
l'hôtel de ville du cap en afrique du
sud nelson mandela est ce soir un homme
libre mais la violence continue en
afrique du sud 14 morts la nuit dernière
une centaine de blessées au cours
d'affrontements entre sympathisants de
l'insee et policiers des images qui nous
arrivent dans le désordre ce sont des
images qui arrivent des affrontements ce
soir au cap où il ya eu un mort et
plusieurs blessés
la police a ouvert le feu sur des jeunes
gens qui lançaient des bouteilles dans
le centre-ville des sources médicales on
confiant qu'une personne transportée à
l'hôpital est morte de blessures par
chevrotine précisant également que 16
autres blessées au moins avaient été
transportés à l'hôpital fin de cette
édition sur ces images de violence en
afrique du sud
je vous retrouve à 22h15 pour soir 3
d'autres développements bien sûr sur la
situation en afrique du sud d'ici là
très bonne soirée à tous
nous
tous